this is a production of Cornell
University
okay well thank you guys for being here
last so hopefully these won't be too
painful I'm having just as a warning my
head feels super hazy right now so I
hope I make sense so don't hold me don't
hold it against me I'll try to keep it
cool so what I'm being working on for
the past three almost four years now
these amaz'n races because they are like
a really cool resource for
environmentally adaptive alleles the way
that I like to think about these land
races is that they're like incredibly
diverse on their genotype because they
have been collected across many years by
transit people thanks to their
collaboration with similar folks and
they also have the representation within
these genotypes of their environmental
diversity in which they have been grown
so that means that they present a really
like a massive bold line of breeding
resources for adaptive alleles and those
basically the the purpose of my PhD has
been out can we leverage these two
things to speed up breeding programs so
the data that I'm working with is this
image mess of this seeds of discovery
project there is a collection of about
5,000 landraces like having collected
all over Latin America I have been
genotype 2 GBS markers these have
approximately like 50% amazing data but
you can impute them and then you have AK
about 300,000 markers on our set the
cool thing about these land races that
have been also identified with the
geographical information so we have the
environments from where they came from
so we know that for example someone
races have a certain temperature growth
or the soil pH or the first frequency
that it's been applying some form of
pressure of selection over there however
many years there farmers have been
keeping them on their application and
the community
these two things is about 3,000
exceptions so it's like how can we
leverage those two to get information
out of them and I just like you always
show this plot because it's because it's
really amazing I really like seeing it
the fact that it's where mace comes from
it's all over and just a array of
conditions that it has been encounter
it's just we should be able to like mind
that out so what I'm going to do is just
discover the beneficial alleles out of
them this under pipeline is you do some
kind of genotyping you do some kind of
Association model and then you finally
validate whatever you find through that
this time the way you would do some kind
of scheme sequencing you map that you
know either very telling
I think you do those things that gives
you the genotypes that if you have some
form of phenotypes and you can do the
Association model but the probably
always you have is that there's some
form of population structure or genetic
architecture it's known in mace to exist
so you have to control for that so that
means that those alleles that you might
find associated to like she was already
just give us approach we're gonna give
you some form of our in selection and
then you have to validate and then you
finally have maybe some potentially cost
alleles and the way we do this on the
data that we have is this kind of
pipeline history so give us markers with
a patient where we're using a
combination of disease geographical
location and a kinship matrix so they
give me like six different kinds of G
was models you try and identify these
things and it actually works there's a
people very came out a couple of years
ago and this Phi 23 no latitude
outpatient but the problem of course is
or the certain limitation that we have
is that this imputation is perfect so if
we look at the correlation of the
imputed alleles with some markers that
we hide so that we can test for that is
like a point six correlation which again
it worked but it can be better
particularly we will think of an
environmental G was modeled what we're
trying to explain the environment you
have to control for the population
structure and we go from something where
the most of the genome looks significant
to another one where we train control
more finally for the population
structure where nothing is so
how can we improve on this even if it
worries you can do some form of a
selection of these variants then you can
like Muscat or Chesterton is another set
of trials for example what can you what
can we improve on that well beginning on
the first part we can change it for like
just the simple fact that we have
genotypes that are highly missing we can
improve that and we be talking about for
a while in our lab of what is the
practical table labor practical
haplotype graph on mates which is a
collection of mace assemblies the
services or haplotypes to improve on the
imputation of the data so the missing
data is reduced potentially we have more
informative alleles or haplotypes and
then the other side is how the way you
do the variant realization or validation
we're thinking of doing this report or
no validation through like mapped
alleles on a different species for
example and I'll be talking a little bit
on both of these things so how can we
improve on that part of the genotyping
well we increase the diversity of the
HEPA dates so I was really surprised
about finding this paper nature where
human geneticists are identifying that
if you have a diverse set of people you
can actually identify better for the
markers of the traits that can be
correlated to that this came back in
June this easier so that basically all
we have on the land races it's a set of
like a diverse population that we can
hopefully is from the mind for better
identifying these adaptive alleles
now the other side is to map or
definitely on a different for example
species so that we don't have the
problem of it being just a sort of
population structure genetic
architecture that can be variable you're
not sooner different species hopefully
then that means that we can actually
test for true causal variants and on
this side
genotyping part mice raggedy lab with a
graph
he said database and a pipeline is a
database of assembly the services source
of haplotypes that we can then use to
map reads against and then give us our
imputed haplotypes that then we can use
to generate you know their association
the way these looks right now hmm sorry
this is a collection of sessions and
this is the number of were recalling
genomic ranges which is used a haplotype
defined by a gene length so in the case
of may see if there's 30-some thousand
genes you have seven thousand genomic
ranges because it's broken by each once
you find a gene in it and this is your
the different next sessions that we have
in the database working with right now
for a lovely thing chromosomes the ones
I have just a couple chromosome is
because there are same listing process
by levers in our group but it's just a
really cool resource to be working with
[Music]
so why do we think this is actually when
I work on the one side we have that the
Maslin races so a sizable portion of IBD
regions so some of the same piece that
we have in database right now our
foursome and land races a similar
sequence and over here we can see that
out of 5,000 unique regions about like
then 20% of them are exactly the same so
we sample enough of them we could
potentially just be having actually the
haplotypes for each of these any regions
that we can then use skin sequencing to
match against that will give us
information but then if we have only the
genic regions how much can we actually
explain of any given phenotype and
apparently we can actually maybe
hopefully map about 70% of the
expression control at least in the maze
leaf that is coming out of this paper
that posted in our lab katherine is
working on and it's actually really cool
I'm sorry my head
analysis that they've been doing because
this is massive effort of 104 mais a
transcription factors and they're
identified the most of them actually by
nearby the genes so there we have that
the Genie regions should be potentially
enough to explain most of the variation
of any given expression that can be can
be associated to a particular trait okay
so how is actually performing on our
land races I finally tested that so we
can compare the GBS as nickels against
the phg nickels and it actually doesn't
perform too bad the problem is we will
of course like to see these little
diagram over here this is from a
distance matrix so basically all
compound comparisons I guess four
thousand and change accessions we would
like to be like a straight line assuming
that the GPS data is correct but then we
have like this blob over here that is
just actually identifying with a higher
distance on these nipples from the bhg
so what we're thinking is we're just
simply missing the correct haplotypes in
the database so we need to increase that
out how do we do that well we increase
the number of habitus in the database
and for that the maze community in
general is assembling all of the non
founders we're hoping to have those
available early next year so that we can
increase the source of these genomic
information also additionally in our lab
we'll be assembling 25 additional see me
maze lights which are inbred the ride
from land races that unit has created
across years there's 500 of them right
now so we selected a few of them to
start to work with and generate more
haplotypes that we can work on we proved
the imputation of the last races and in
that sense we're trying say ready for
the same blurs in the lab and the cool
thing is that is working pretty neatly
at least on the haplotype level that
we're thinking of gene sense because
there's this tool that in July we
developed a task was just mask is
relatedly mapping is a gene they're
serious regions for the Kings against
the genome how many of them we are
actually to recover you can identify how
complete the genes are being assembled
through it
we have the most of them are actually
founded so we are pretty hopeful that we
should be able to have a working said
early next year as well for the Seavey's
mines and that's it
like to thank everyone in the doctor lab
guess this is basically the work of
everyone in they're both growing the
plans to take issues and actually
analyzing the data echoes sometimes you
don't know what you're doing but you're
doing it and then eventually so it's
[Applause]
alright you have other evidence to
suggest that those are uniquely diverse
and the rest that completely so I
haven't checked pacifically the
individual regions that we're having
problems for their land races because
the truth that we have is it's
incomplete is GBS data we do have more
information for some other lines as part
of the genomes of field project where
they have like a whole genome sequence
data that has better allele codes that
we can test against that and we can see
there's there some specific genes where
the errors are actually found in a
subset of them so this is specific
regions of the genome where most of the
errors are actually I found so as part
of the same trying to figure out what's
going on I did some gene trees for the
most error prone regions and they tend
to be the most diverse ones so there's
like the most with the most branches of
the smallest clusters so that the
Sailing is that we just basically we
don't have representation for those
within our working sure yes
simply as we have right now yeah so most
of the assemblies are just different
material that's been made available by
massive group of people but it's just
we're thinking is just this sort of a
clientele difference of this stuff has
been sequences temporary material as
being grown in the US as opposed to
everything else in the world so it's
sort of its best way I actually thought
of putting that paper from them human
genetic size because you have this work
instead of European Caucasian people
where they're identifying these risk
scores and they're finding that once you
add up actually the alleles coming from
a more diverse group of people that
includes people from Eurasia or Africa
they're like completely restoring them
finding out that what is a rare allele
in Europe is completely normal in other
populations it allows you to like not
say that something is actually as
controlling for a given trait that's the
good thought it was
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at Cornell edu